معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك معنا ابدا معك بالخبر
العاجل الذي اوردناه قبل قليل نقلا عن
اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بوجود تقديرات
داخل الجيش بان المعارك في خان يونس تحتاج
لاشهر لحسمها كيف تقرا هذا
الاعلان نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
نعم لا شك بان هذه التصريح تعطي دلاله
واضحه على ان المعركه صعبه وشرسه وقويه
ولا يمكن انجاز هذه المهمه التي اعطيت الى
هذا الجيش منذ اكثر من 72 يوم بالسرعه
التي يريدها الكثير من القاده سواء كانوا
على المستوى السياسي او على المستوى
المدني لان هناك ضغوطات كبيره جدا خاصه من
اهالي الاسرى على القياده السياسيه
والقياده العسكريه بانه يجب استرجاع
اولادهم الذين يتواجدون في قطاع غزه كاسرى
وبالتالي هم يريدون انهاء هذه العمليه
العسكريه ولكن ترى القيادات العسكريه بانه
هذه العمليه قد تطول لانه هناك مقاومه
شرسه ولا يمكن ان يتم تحقيق اهداف العمليه
العسكريه بالسهوله التي يتوقعها البعض
لذلك هم يحاولون ان يعطون يعني من الان
بانه يمكن ان تطول هذه المعركه لفتره
قادمه وهي جزء من الضغوط النفسيه ايضا
والضغوط التي تمارس على قياده حماس في
الداخل وتمارس على على القيادات العسكريه
خاصه بانه سوف تستمر هذه العمليه ولن
تتوقف ويجب الرضوخ للشروط التي وضعتها
اسرائيل في مساله ايقاف الحرب وبالتالي
نحن نتكلم عن ارادتين اراده تقاوم واراده
تحاول الوصول الى اهدافها من خلال الهجوم
الذي تقوم به منذ 7 اكتوبر والى يومنا هذا
طيب ما الذي يجعل المعارك في خان يونس
تحديدا تتطلب كل هذا الوقت لحسمها مع
العلم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي وجه مقاومه
الشرسه ايضا في مناطق
اخرى
نعم جيش الاحتلال يرى بان المنطقه
الشماليه تم التوغل في كثير من المناطق
التي دخل اليها في الفتره الماضيه
وبالتالي تقريبا يعني يرى بان العمليات لن
تطول في شمال في الشمال لذلك هو يحاول ان
يلجا الى الجنوب وان هذه المعركه لازالت
في بدايتها يعني اذا ما اردنا ان نتكلم عن
المرحله الثانيه فهي بدات بعد المرحله
الاولى فلذلك هو يحاول ان يقول بان
المعركه في خان يونس قد تاخذ بعض الوقت
لان هناك الكثير من المناطق التي لا زالت
خارج سيطره القوات العسكريه لجيش لجيش
الاحتلال وبالتالي هو يحاول ان يعطي بعض
الاشارات بانه قد تطول هذه المعركه عندما
يتكلم عن خان يونس هو يريد ان يقنع الراي
الداخلي بانه تقريبا قطاع شمال غزه قد
انتهت المعارك فيه ولم تبقى الا منطقه او
منطقتين لم يتم الدخول اليها فلذلك هو
تحول كانما يريد ان يقول طط سيد فلاحي
اعتذر منك على المقاطعه ابقى معنا فقط لكي
نشير الى هذه الصور صور التي تاتينا
مباشره من غزه تظهر قصفا في منطقه شمال
غزه ونحن نشاهد سحب الدخان بعد هذا القصف
الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف منطقه في شمال
قطاع
غزه اذا هذه الصور مشاهدينا تاتينا مباشره
من
غزه بعد قصف اسرائيلي
استهدف منطقه في شمال
القطاع ونشاهد سحب دخان في سماء هذه
المنطقه بعد هذا القصف ونسمع ايضا دوي
انفجارات في هذه
الاثناء طبعا هذا القصف يتزامن مع قصف
اسرائيلي ايضا لمناطق اخرى في قطاع
غزه منها شرق منها خانيونس التي تشهد ايضا
معارك شرسه بين فصائل المقاومه وقوات
الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الان نعود الى ضيفنا السيد
الفلاحي حتى الان حديث عن تقديرات هناك
فرق بين التقديرات والخطط هل يمكن
لاسرائيل فع
ان تستغرق شهورا في معاركها في خان يونس
خصوصا مع الضغط الان فيما يتعلق بموضوع
الاسره وايضا سلامه الجنود خلال هذه
المعارك نعم الان المرحله حقيقه دخلت في
المرحله الثانيه وهذه المرحله الثانيه هي
اشد من المرحله الاولى بكثير لانه دائما
عندما تنتهي المعركه الاولى يبدا التخطيط
للمعركه الثانيه والثالثه وبالتالي هذه
المعركه صعبه وحاسم لكلا الطرفين ولكن نرى
بان انه كفه الميزان الان بدات تنقلب خاصه
في الشمال يعني العمليات العسكريه كبيره
والخسائر كبيره بالنسبه لقوات الاحتلال
انا اعتقد بانه هذه التصريحات التي يصرح
قاده الاحتلال هم يعطون حقيقه واضحه لما
يدور في المعارك في سواء كانت في الشمال
او في الجنوب لذلك نعم ستطول هذه المعارك
طالما اصر الطرفين على الاستمرار في هذه
المعركه وطالما اسر الطرفين على تحقيق
اهدافهم
فالمداعبة توقف اطلاق شامل وان يكون هناك
تبادل للاسرى بشكل كامل بينما الطرف الاخر
يريد ان
يحقق اهدافه بتدمير القدرات العسكريه وبعد
ذلك اطلاق سراح الاسرى بالقوه يعني هو يصر
على المقاربه الامنيه واذا ما اردت ان
اعلق على هاتين الغارتين فقط الان اقول
ماذا لو كانوا الاسرى في هذه المواقع التي
قصفت الان من قبل طيران الاحتلال كيف سيتم
اعاده الاسرى بالقوه ومن خلال العمليات
الخاصه اذا كان القصف بهذا المستوى يعني
هذا الكلام ينافي تماما ما تصرح به
القيادات العسكريه من يريد استعاده الاسرى
لا يقوم بالقصف بهذه الطريقه التدميريه
التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى تدمير كل ما موجود
في هذه البنايه يجب ان يقوم بعمليه القتال
من بيت الى بيت ومن شارع الى شارع حتى يتم
التوصل الى الاسرى ولكن
هذه التصريحات لا تنم عن وعي كامل وتنم
على انه لا يريدون استعاده الاسرى وانما
هذه القضيه قضيه ثانويه بالنسب لحكومه
نتنياهو مع ذلك يقولون الان انهم او
يتحدثون عن امكانيه ايه عقد الصفقه وانهم
مستعدون لذلك ويجري بحث هذا الامر في
الوقت الذي تقول فيه المقاومه انها ترفض
اي صفقه قبل وقف العدوان كيف نقرا هذه
المساله وما الذي تقوله لنا عن الوضع في
الميدان نعم الان هناك ضغوطات داخليه
كبيره جدا هذه الضغوطات تقول بانه يجب
استعاده الاسرى وهم يحاولون ان يذهبون الى
هدى كما حصل في المرحله الاولى هدى
انسانيه او هدى ل لوقت قليل لفتره معينه
يتم خلالها تبادل الاسرى ثم بعد ذلك
يعودون الى القتال مره اخرى هذا ما ترفضه
قياده حماس وترفضه قياده المقاومه في
الداخل يقولون يجب ان يكون هناك وقف اطلاق
نار كامل والا لن يكون هناك وقف لاطلاق
النار اولا هناك خسائر يتكبدها الجيش الان
في جميع المناطق تقريبا وراينا بالامس على
العمليه
جحر الديك يعني هذه العمليه تدخل ضمن
تعبئه عندما نقول كيف ستطول المعارك تدخل
ضمن تعبئه القتالات الخاصه بالتسلل خلف
خطوط العدو والقيام بتدمير مناطق معينه
وتدخل ك ايضا في سلسله الغارات يعني تكون
غاره من قبل قوى متحركه باتجاه هدف كامل
في منطقه معينه ويت يتم تدمير هذا الهدف
ثم العوده الى القاعده الامينه التي
انطلقوا منها اذا نحن نتكلم عن معارك شرسه
ونتكلم عن اخفق بالنسبه للجيش الاحتلال في
مساله اداره المعركه الدفاعيه على جميع
المستويات وهذه التكتيكات التي تقوم بها
حماس هي مؤذيه بشكل كبير جدا عندما تتسلل
خلف خطوط العدو الى عمق مناطق العدو التي
سيطر عليها في الفتره الماضيه من اك منذ
الايام الاولى للهجوم ثم تقوم بتدمير قوه
تعود لقواته في هذه المنطقه وتحصل على
اسلحتها ثم تعود اذا نحن نتكلم عن معركه
متحركه سياله فيها عمليات يمكن ان تنفذ
ويمكن ان تؤدي الى خسائر نقول بانه يجب
الوقوف عندها بالنسبه لقوات الاحتلال
فلذلك المعركه ستكون طويله اذا ما استمر
الطرفين بهذه القضيه والطرفين يصرون على
التمسك بموقفهم لا هدن انسانيه ولا تبادل
للاسرى ما لم يكن هناك وقف اطلاق نار كامل
ويكون ايضا هذا من خلال اطراف اخرى تدخل
ضمن الاطراف الضامنه لتنفيذ هذا الاتفاق
ولكن ما تفسيرك لنقطه ان حماس كانت في
السابق ترحب حتى بهد انسانيه الان لا تريد
اي صفقه دون وقف كامل للعدوان ما تفسيرك
لهذا
الموقف نعم في بعض الامرار هذه الهدن يعني
تكون في ظروف تعبو صعبه فعندما تريد
التخلص من موقف تعبوي معين يتم الذهاب الى
مثل هذه الهدن ولكن عندما تكون هذه الهدن
لا تصب في مصلحه المقاتل في الداخل ولا
تصب في مصلحه الاهداف العامه التي وضعتها
القياده بالنسبه لهذه الحرب فيذهبون طرفين
الى الاصرار على موقفهم وعدم القبول بمثل
هذه الهدن لان هذه الهدن عندما تنتهي
سنعود الى القتال مره اخرى الاضافه الى
ذلك بان لدي اوراق قوه من ضمن هذه الاوراق
القوه هي مساله الاسرى المتواجدين في داخل
قطاع غزه طبعا هذه الورقه لا يمكن التفريط
بها بسهوله بهذه الكيفيه خصوصا وانه تم
اطلاق راح المدنيين من النساء والرجال
والاطفال وبقيت القيادات التي تخص جيش
الاحتلال يعني هناك قيادات على مستويات
عاليه لا يمكن ان افرط به
الورقه بالقبول بهد انسانيه لمده يومين او
ثلاث لا يجب ان تكون الشروط عاليه في هذه
القضيه ويجب الاستمرار حتى يتم الرضوخ
لهذه الشروط هذا ما يجري الان من قبل
الطرفين شكرا لك حاتم كريم الفلاحي العقد
العقيد الركن والخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من اسطنبول